reinvención y unidad de sevilla puede
ser el lema de emanuel a marco para los
próximos cinco años aquí en el campo de
marte con a la torre eiffel
como fondo pues emanuel ama con celebró
su victoria y su reelección a la
presidencia de francia agradeció por
supuesto a aquellas personas que votaron
por él pero también en especial a
aquellas personas que votaron por él no
por adhesión sino para hacer frente y
frenar la llegada de la extrema derecha
al elíseo el hablaba de reinvención de
cinco años en los que ella pueda hacer
tener un nuevo método para construir
algo mejor una sociedad más justa una
sociedad en la que los hombres y las
mujeres sean más más iguales pero
también hablaba de una sociedad en la
que hay que trabajar en la unidad del
sabe que hay mucha rabia que hay mucho
desacuerdo y que estas personas deben
ser escuchadas y es él quien debe darles
respuesta esta no fue una celebración
llena de júbilo de ese jolgorio que se
vivió hace cinco años sino en realidad
fue una celebración un poco parca de
casi de alivio para las personas que
estaban aquí presentes quienes hasta el
último momento sintieron incertidumbre
de lo que podía terminar esta segunda
vuelta por ahora queda saber cuál será
la estrategia de manuel mccone para las
elecciones legislativas del mes de junio
porque de esa elección él no habló en su
discurso